j'avise le gouvernement et je manquais
auprès des autres formations politiques
si tenté que quelqu'un pense que le bloc
québécois a voté en faveur de traiter
qui sacrifie l'aluminium québécois ce
sera non l'industrie de l'aluminium au
canada principal principalement au
québec pourrait faire les frais de cette
nouvelle entente c'est pour ça que vous
venez d'entendre le bloc québécois qui
va s'opposer finalement à l'entente on
va parler avec jean simard président et
chef de la direction de l'association
d'aluminium bonsoir bonsoir
qu'est ce qui est différent maintenant
pour le secteur de l'aluminium et qui ne
l'est pas pour la 6 mais en fait si on
se rappelle à l'origine dans l'entente
dont vous avez souligné dans la
réalisation il ya plusieurs mois un
pardon il ya une clause de contenu
régional qui a été mise en vigueur qui
en fait qui a été négocié de façon à
assurer que 70 % du contenu régional en
termes de métaux incidemment l'aluminium
et d'acier soit assurée à partir de ce
qui est produit sur le continent
nord-américain nord-américain les pays
membres alors nous avons après avoir
examiné cette entente là conclut comme
industrie qu'il fallait aller plus loin
en utilisant en définissant de façon
plus détaillée plus approfondie la
notion de ce que c'est de l'aluminium
qui est produit sur dans l'espace du de
l'accord et pour réaliser qu'en fait le
ce que cette règle leur permettait
c'était de s'assurer que le fabricant
automobile par exemple dans la mesure où
il achète directement du métal pour
fabriquer des composantes qui entrent
dans le véhicule
à la fin que ce métal a fait partie du
pourcentage celui qu'ils se procurent
directement or le marché ne fonctionne
pas comme ça les grands fabricants
automobiles n'achète pas de métal
directement du producteur de métal ils
achètent le métal des grands laminoir
qui sont situées aux états unis qui eux
peuvent s'approvisionner à peu près
n'importe où dans le monde
donc aucune assurance pour les
producteurs d'aluminium primaire du
canada que le marché va répondre à ce
signal politique et modifier un
comportement pour se procurer du métal
qui est fabriqué ici donc on a demandé
de mettre une règle la règle d'un
contenu régional basé sur du métal qui
écoulait produit sur le continent soit
au canada ou aux états unis et on le
paye
alors on le produit le une épaule et
sodium est ce qu'on visait c'était de
corriger entre autres une faille qu'on
appelle la faille mexicaine qui veut que
le mexique s'est constitué un marché en
utilisant du métal importés de chine à
moindre prix qui transforme pour par la
suite l'envoyer en produits qui entrent
dans des composantes sur le marché
automobile et les chiffres sont très
claires on va vous les montrer les
exportations de chine vers les etats
unis ont baissé de 60% dans les jantes
en aluminium de mai à juillet 2010 9 mai
de la chine vers le mexique ont grimpé
de 240 % et ensuite du mexique vers les
états unis un os 2 260% éventuelle d'un
jeu de marché très clair la chine est en
train d'entrer par le mexique ou aux
états unis
exactement alors notre détriment à notre
détriment
de plus en plus on perd des parts de
marché parce qu'on a des entreprises
qu'on approvisionner jusqu'à maintenant
sur le marché américain qui ne
renouvelle pas les commandes soit parce
qu'elles se relocalise au mexique pour
avoir accès du métal moins cher ou parce
que simplement elles perdent leur
commande au profit de fabricants d'un
producteur au mexique réaction de
christophe gijon la vice première
ministre qui est toujours à mexico les
changements qu'on a fait aujourd'hui
n'ont pas changé le traitement
d'aluminium dans de nouvelles à la main
nous n'avons pas changé
l'aluminium dans la cohorte c'est ça le
canada dit on à riez perdu on n'a rien
changé et la raison ne rien changer nous
ont demandé de changer et c'est ce qu'on
n'a pas eu la 6e demandé de changer
il l'a eu le canada demandé de changer
madame guylaine supporter notre position
jusqu'au bout et puis on le reconnaît
puis on la remercie
mais on n'a pas eu gain de cause et il
ce qu'on demandait c'est une
modification pour colmater la brèche la
faille que représente le mexique dans ce
corridor de livres et chant quelles
seront les conséquences pour les
alumineries avait-elle immigré au québec
principalement mais on va comme je
mentionnais on commence déjà à perdre
des morceaux comme on dit on perd des
clients sur le marché américain puis
même sur le marché canadien qui commence
à soi être remplacés par des
fournisseurs mexicain pour le marché
américain où soit se relocaliser ou
refaire leur logistique
d'approvisionnement par le mexique parce
que ils ont accès du métal moins cher
que demandez-vous aujourd'hui on demande
au gouvernement
premièrement on va on va analyser tous
les pourtours de 7 cette annonce là
dessus du protocole comme ont été
mentionnés tout à l'heure et on va aller
voir on va s'asseoir avec le
gouvernement que les autorités
québécoises et fédérales pour s'assurer
de
de faire ce qu'il faut pour assurer la
compétitivité de notre industrie dans un
marché qui vient de subir un changement
qui vient affecter nos parts de marché
et aussi insisté auprès du gouvernement
fédéral de faire toutes les
représentations qui s'impose avec les
américains pour forcer le mexique a
respecté les règles du jeu c'est ce
qu'on va voir jean simard merci beaucoup
je vous en prie aussi bien